hey youtubers it's Charlie so this gonna
be a breakdown of that tiny size Marvel
ant-man trailer I know it's totally
where they posted that but the full
trailer is going to be posting next
Tuesday during the agent Carter premiere
don't worry if you're not able to watch
agent Carter on TV they'll still post
the trailer online so everyone's gonna
be able to watch it important stuff
first so in case you had trouble seeing
the tiny footage I tried to blow it up
just a little bit it's just shots of
each of the characters the full trailer
next week is gonna spell out what the
story is gonna be you see Paul Rudd here
a Scott Lang getting hauled off by the
law he's a thief in the comics and those
skills are gonna be really important to
the plot of this movie Corey Stoll as we
see here plays Darren cross he's the
main villain of the film he Bogaerts
Hank Pimm's technology to create his own
shrinking suit and calls himself yellow
jacket they actually just released some
high-res promo art that you probably saw
I mean I posted in my agent Carter video
all I'm wondering is is you know what he
does with these extra arms it was
actually funny listening to Corey Stoll
talk about his character at the
comic-con panel it's just the way that
you know most villains don't think of
themselves as villains I was Hank Pimm's
mint tea and the the genius scientist as
well and I am now I've taken over the
company and some very judgmental people
may think that that's in an evil
direction but I think I'm just taking it
into the into the future and I know a
lot of you have been asking me on
Twitter about yellowjacket yes
in the comics Hank Pym was yellowjacket
he used that name later it was co-opted
by a female villain the movie is
changing that they're changing the
backstory and in the comics they're also
changing Darin crosses backstory just a
little bit too he was kind of like a
corporate competitor for Stark
Industries Trask and Oscorp eventually
he started to die perform this crazy
surgery on himself and as a result of a
transplant mutated and got minor powers
so he was a villain in the comics
they're just they're making him more of
like an evil Hank Pym although Hank Pym
is kind of evil in the comics at certain
points too well maybe not evil but a
little bit crazy there actually was some
crossover between the Scott Lang ant-man
and Darren cross in the comics he was
trying to find the doctor that performed
Darren crosses life-saving surgeries so
that
could do the same thing for his daughter
who was also dying the movies
downplaying some of the Scott Lang
comic-book backstory but he still has a
daughter and he's still going to be a
thief if you are a big fan of ant-man in
the comics just expect some changes I
mean Marvel does it with all its movies
so I think people are starting to get
used to that hank pym of course played
by Michael Douglas he's actually gonna
be a really interesting addition to the
Marvel Universe watching him Old Manse
playing the movie during the Comic Con
panel was probably one of the most fun
things ever like it was like he was
trying to explain who ant-man was to
like a sea of comic book nerds who had
been reading ant-man their whole lives
it was is pretty funny there was also
that cherry popping moment it was just
like the icing on the cake here's
actually here's the clip of that in case
you didn't see it
and it is as advertised this is
unbelievable this michaelis I never
thought I would say this we were also
popping your cherry I posted the entire
ant-man comic-con panel and the Avengers
panel if you guys want to watch those
after this video so I'll add links in
the description in the movie though Hank
Pym and list Scott Lang's help to take
down Darren cross and get his Pym tech
back for those wondering about Edgar
Wright's version of the movie how that
was different in his version Scott Lang
was less of a thief he was working at
Hank pimp's company as a scientist the
dotter storyline was there but it was a
little bit different too so this version
of the story is actually a little bit
closer to the Scott Lang origin story in
the comics I think the final version of
the movie just paints Scott Lang is more
of an average Joe type person like he's
less of a Tony Stark figure working with
Hank Pym and yes I do think there is
potential for him to end up in a future
Avengers movie like an Avengers infinity
war but I really don't know enough about
the movie to speculate on that yet
here we see hope Van Dyne played by
Evangeline Lilly she's also a big part
of team Pym in the movie like her mother
is Janet Van Dyne but in all the
interviews that everyone has done they
have never mentioned Janet so by all
accounts she's probably not in the movie
in a big way and she's probably dead
they will probably mention her whenever
they have like Hank and hoped
father/daughter scenes I believe they
mentioned that hope is going to be
estranged from Hank Pym like they'll
have a very strained relationship I
can't remember a movie that Michael
Douglas has been in where he's had a
daughter in the film that he's had a
good relationship with really you know I
think we all just want to know if hope
is going to take the mantle from her
mother and become the wasp like that
would be awesome I feel like they
wouldn't have cast Evangeline Lilly if
they didn't want to go in that direction
she kind of just got done being a
superhero elf in The Hobbit trilogy
there was a story arc in the comics
where an alternate universe version of
Hope named Hope Pym became Red Queen but
she was kind of a villain so it's just
one of the other small changes to the
comics that the movies making that's
pretty much it for this you know tiny
sized trailer but the full trailer next
week is gonna have a ton of footage
it'll be like that first Avengers
trailer it'll be nice
long I'll totally do a full breakdown
whenever it posts so be sure to
subscribe to get that it's gonna be on
the same day as agent Carter so I'll do
my ant-man video first and then I'll do
my agent Carter video I will say it's
probably gonna be like the weirdest
movie Marvel has done so far next -
guardians of the galaxy I think it was
more of a comedy when Edgar Wright was
working on it but I do still think that
ant-man will be Marvel's first proper
comedy with a lot of action in it like
they're not gonna do a Marvel movie
without action I do consider guardians
of the galaxy a comedy but I think it's
an action movie first like it's an
action movie with a lot of comedy if
anyone's still wondering why Edgar
Wright left the movie it was mostly just
because of all the script changes they
made I think he he said like finally
when it was all said and done that it
wasn't because of you know anything bad
it was just that by the time they got to
where they were in the script process
the movie was no longer his it was no
longer recognizable as the movie that he
had written he has like a very
particular style with the films that he
makes and I think it was just hard to
fit that into Marvel's system like
Marvel has a very specific tone and look
that they're going for in all their
films they try to make all the film's
really consistent so I think you know
whenever you bring in a director with a
very particular style is just it's
really hard to fit that in the new
director Peyton Reed is also known for
doing a lot of smaller comedies mostly
TV stuff his most recent work that you
probably seen has been new girl he's
done a couple episodes of that he did
upright citizens per grade which i think
is totally awesome he did mr. show on
HBO and he even did this weird al'
yankovic TV show so they would not have
hired him if they didn't want ant-man to
be a comedy for those that are asking
about where this movie fits in to the
Marvel verse and the timeline this is
going to be like the last movie in phase
2 whenever they first announced the
movie whenever they were first
conceiving of it it was going to be the
first movie in phase 3 but I think with
all the changes they made they just
decided it worked better with the tone
and what was going on between the first
and second Avengers films so by all
accounts just assume this is happening
around the events of Avengers 2 like
somewhere near to that maybe not right
at the same time once they start doing
more press for the film they start doing
more interviews
they'll probably explain that a little
bit better those are always like the
biggest questions you know where does
this fit in with the other movies and
are we going to see these characters in
the other movies like in The Avengers
movies
I am really hoping that we get to see
Evangeline Lilly and Paul Rudd and
Avengers infinity war now that would
totally be awesome
I can understand though if that movie
gets too bloated with characters they
want to leave them out I was planning on
talking about my top 5 ant-man stories
in this video but because it started to
get a little too long I'm just gonna do
a separate video for that the really
cool news though is that Marvel is
releasing a brand new Scott Lang ant-man
comic written by a Nick Spencer on
surprise surprise January 7th next
Wednesday they're releasing like the
brand-new run of the comics the day
after they post the trailer for the
movie so you see how that works it's
supposed to be just as awesome as Matt
fractions run on Hawkeye so if you're a
big fan of that definitely check out the
new ant-man comic here's some of the
preview pages it looks like he's going
to be interacting a lot with Tony Stark
in and around Stark Industries and
actually you know what I think I'm gonna
do a giveaway for this trailer video
that I'll post on Tuesday I'll give away
comiXology gift cards so people who win
can buy the comic if they want let me
know if you guys would like me to do
that more often like do comiXology gift
cards instead of just straight-up Amazon
gift cards all you have to do to enter
that though is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on my ant-man trailer video
whenever I post that next week I will
remind everyone when I post the video so
so no worries right now if you're on
your mobile phone or on your tablet you
can click up here there's new mobile
links it's just the same as the links
over here but you can click here for my
agent Carter preview of again the
Avengers trailer is coming on January
12th I think I said February in the
video but you can also click here for
the rest of my Marvel Avengers phase 3
videos thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five I will see you guys
tonight
you